good evening good evening
good evening
tonight's main course halibut
let's get on with the startup first
shall we good evening nice to see you
four hard-working northern farm girls
yes yes yes
welcome thank you how are you susan fine
thank you judith hi thank you yes yes
yes
sandra three sisters who's got one now
me justin what are you doing my darling
i sell sexy times you sell septic tanks
yeah bottom end of the market
so you're dealing with [ __ ] all day yes
absolutely yeah that's one thing we're
not gonna do this evening is deal with
[ __ ]
yes yes yes chef the highest scoring
brigade
okay across the whole series they're
coming to run my rational clarities
yes really so judith what's on the menu
pea salad with poached
uh duck egg and pancetta right off we go
four killers table eight
on order four duck salad four halibut
four scotch pancake yes yeah
excellent cool that [ __ ] squeak right
let me show you
how to do the first table first thing
that goes on lardons
basically little matchsticks cut out of
pancetta yes yes okay
we put them in a hot pan now to get rid
of the excess fat so we get this really
nice crispy lardon at the end okay
our water's spinning around there nicely
yes vinegar's in there
and then it's turning around that way so
we go in up and straight in yes
okay what have you got in there bringing
in chives
vinaigrette i don't want the peas too
hot they get too hot they discolor okay
i'm gonna put the lavender straight in
there okay yes toss it all together
nice four portions little taste and
margarine please sandra
pick margarine right at the last minute
in there now the idea of the yolk
is for what yeah the ninth richness of
the yolk you have to give a really nice
sort of sauce effect
for the peas right if the anchovy
fingers are small don't be scared to
serve four okay
eggs out please nice and carefully
plates down
nice simple straightforward cooking
thank you for the pepper good
looks watch a few margarine on top of
the egg fresh margarine
go please and then a really nice
tapenade all of you one simple question
would you pay eight pounds for that yeah
you're [ __ ] better because i made it
all like that yes
right let's go ladies please
no answer who's whistling me who
what are you whistling at cause i'm just
i don't know susan yeah
how does your boyfriend put it with that
voice
yeah we got one [ __ ] me that's not a
[ __ ] surprise are you still single
mr frenchman no go please yes a single
white loud female
yes doesn't know a [ __ ] egg from a
peas and pisses in the bath on a [ __ ]
holiday
even the knees must how could you do
that to your friends so it's rainbow
shirt in a room yeah
i frank got in afterwards
she's squashing water on her face and i
said oh don't do that and chill
please i said a week but you've got a
morning after a face was gorgeous
uh ladies the confidence levels is
fantastic yes
keep it up yes someone's toast is
burning toast is burning
let me set an alarm on that [ __ ]
grill yes no chef come on lady wait
you're waking
you may eat [ __ ] burnt toast up north
but we're in [ __ ] london
some more on down it's like [ __ ]
ill-derogated
yes they're burnt they'll be all right
yeah well when they burst that egg you
want the egg yolk the richness
oh there you go running all over the
piece right well done very very nice
indeed go please yes
14. let's go quick
it's nice to be back in the kitchen with
women for a change
i'll get up about 10 past five do a milk
round
usually finish work around about 5 30
pick the children up
work in the tea shop all day long
at first four in the morning the alarm
goes off so i get up do the milk round
i love to cook dessert chocolate lemon
meringue roulade
could be anything from rose peas bread
steak chicken medium gets quite stressed
with each other when we work together
something's burning in here
we're from lancaster we really sort of
up front and in your face basically if
sandra and judith do is they're told
everything will be paramount it just
says
we will be the best regret that gordon's
ever had because we're hard-working
conscientious girls you've gone and
showed something i'm going to shout back
because he came into this world exactly
the same as me and he's going to go out
to this world
exactly the same as me so look how good
and here we come
sandra
[Music]
right you're supposed to be toasting
you're not burning it yes clean up it's
so
messy unbelievable
let's go let's go let's go eggs please
oh my god
what's your favorite daughter take a
deep breath my restaurant
toast what is it with you burning toast
i always burn it who
nice very nice very very nice well done
well done well done
clear down yes get ready for the next
course yes well done
the egg was a bit snotty and also the
answers are overpowering just too salty
the that pig was lovely yeah it's
something i've never tried before so
very nice thank you let's go let's go
let's go please come over
results yes for the starter okay jb yep
give me the ticket please
out of 50.
only 33. oh what are they saying
come on egg whites two raw egg whites
and yeah and the presentation
presentation
yeah i saw the place yeah i thought you
did a [ __ ] good job no no
may cause make sure you get 50 out of
15. okay
let's go next on the menu the knees van
out and makes me forget my table manners
doesn't andrew lloyd webber's face but
you're concerned
the raf take fast food to mach 2.
not even in there yet i've already wet
my hands oh my god
holy [ __ ] and i challenge top gears
james may
to a culinary jewel this is bull's penis
bull's penis
[Music]
james how are you very good good to see
you man nice shirt
thank you it's one of my regulars how
was your starter
uh very tasty yes to be honest it's sort
of almost a posh fryer you've got bacon
a poached egg um and then you've got
like the bubble and squeak but without
the potato
bit um right top kid you're always
portrayed as the
wimp the one that's always coming behind
jeremy behind hammond
classes of god hammond's become a hero
on the back of the crash
i'm just a bloke i'm not married i don't
have any kids i have a cat
i can turn that around and show them
that you're the most manly out all three
of them i've got an idea simple little
test uh jp please
it's the test of a man it's a test of a
real man it's
snake whiskey it's from laos that is a
real snake in there
ah well done any thoughts
ah it's quite light really it's quite
quite light yeah you spent too much time
with us clark you know that
second please joey this is this is
ball's penis
this is for me this is this this is to
prove your manliness
it's huge in china it's huge on your
plate
it's very good for getting things going
uh sort of downstairs um
any particular well i'll have i'll have
the stem where it all starts
from from from the side sort of from
there to there
that's the hilt isn't it
i'll go under the helmet so this is a
bull's [ __ ] yes
and this has probably been in a lady
cows and
i'd like to i'd like to think so i want
that poor ball to die happy
it's all right actually that was going
to say it's a bit stiff but i didn't
mean that
i forgot to say this
[Laughter]
right the biggest challenge thanks jeffy
now this one is extraordinary
this is a this is
an amazing delicacy from iceland it's a
blue whale's penis
and it's basically rotten shark now it's
being
put in the ground yeah covered in gravel
for up to three months
um on the back of that it's hung for
four months and it is
a local delicacy in a way that you have
to eat it without being sick
and that is the sort of true definition
of a proper man
yes god it does [ __ ] interesting oh
my god
ah traditionally okay it's washed down
with the glass of
brenovin okay it's like a rich fire
water
ready buddy no pull that bucket out
one two three
oh [ __ ] you disappoint me ramsay
damn god almighty did you shoot it yeah
oh james you want me to do it again
congratulations well done bloody hell oh
i wouldn't actually recommend that i
will put you
yes at the top of the pole thank you
hammond second yeah
clarkson third thank you very much
brilliant well
that
done
we're cooking fish now nice and gentle
it's just as delicate as poaching an egg
so potatoes have been part boiled so
what we've got to do now is some colour
on there
yes watch the seasoning please ladies
yes
yes chef turn the halibut yeah
hi tonight's main course is a tandoori
spike halibut with a cucumber aita
[Music]
halibut absolutely perfect this time of
year the season runs from april to
november
and it's a great alternative to cod it's
very robust but it's got this really
nice
snowflake appearance it's bright wide
full of flavor
and packed with protein skin
hold it towards the tail and just tug
the tail
beautiful look all you do now
you just cut nice big thick slabs of
halibut
into the fridge to firm up now we're
gonna make this really
amazing fresh tandoori paste starting
off with some ginger
garlic cumin coriander seeds and the
spices here we've got chili turmeric
paprika
and garam masala basically a hot warm
spice
roast seeds salt and that sort of
intensifies the flavor take a small knob
of ginger
anti-roll thompson size knob peel
great at ginger into the pestle and
mortar three cloves of garlic
[Music]
toasted seeds in salt
spice lemon
that starts to turn the paste with a
really nice sharp vibrant
fresh flavor which you never get when
you buy a tandoori paste
tomato puree and then a couple of
tablespoons
of groundnut oil mix the color
is extraordinary you don't get that
color when you buy a paste
done absolutely beautiful now marinade
in the halibut
yogurt paste lemon
sugar just to sort of chill the flavor
of the heat
with all the spices mix look at that
color now
beautiful halibut in it goes
spoon the marinade over the halibut hot
pan
ground oil straight into the pan
leave that cooking nice and gently for
about two and a half to three minutes
each side we're gonna serve it on a bit
of cucumber
[Applause]
peel look
these wonderful strips almost like
papridelli pasta beautiful
cucumber into a bowl season
mint chop
yogurt lemon absolutely amazing
cucumber in the center of the plate
you've halibut
is ready to come out and watch
mmm smells amazing tandoori spiced
halibut with cucumber aita
done
so the idea of the right yeah is to cool
it down yes yeah so
cucumber mint and yogurt fresh lime
juice at the very end
on potatoes at the top yes chef
sandra please do not burn yeah the
potatoes like you did with the [ __ ]
toast yes
spinach on the side yeah okay then from
there fish out
listen yeah up very carefully go onto
your tray
and move it over but yeah be very very
careful yeah
a little bit vinegar just a touch in
there over now anyone complains about
the presentation there
yeah they can [ __ ] themselves okay 50
like that i guarantee
50 will pay yes let's go yes let's go
ladies please
i don't want it boiling i want a nice
coating
yeah of the marinade on there yes right
okay
really nice coating excuse me let's go
[Music]
sandra julius you need to keep an eye on
how long the fish has been in for
minimum
five minutes yes color and turn chef
chef is the fish ready now should i tell
you all right
[ __ ] voice susan yes why haven't you
managed to get a fella i don't
understand okay
okay too picky yeah you've got to be in
the synergy there's some squats out
there
you know when you go on that first date
do you speak or you just sit there
silent
oh can you imagine a beach quest quiet
gently it's fish yes
two tickets down yes come on fast food
doesn't have to mean
bad food
[Music]
raf lucas scotland home of one of the
world's fastest planes
the tornado f3
the pilots and navigators here are all
on qra
quick reaction alert when the alarm
sounds they have just minutes to
scramble
to defend british airspace these guys
work at top speed but when it comes to
the kitchen they haven't got a clue
how to be quick morning oh the main
problem with time during the day we
actually get about maybe half an hour
for lunch
we don't really know how to cook healthy
food quickly at all that's why we're at
the moment
in the short gap between flying we're
eating pretty rubbish food the state
we're in to be honest
we're reduced to uh cheese toasties
which is pretty
adventurous really for a bunch of men
that fly very expensive nice toys
these guys say they have no time to cook
but i'm here to prove no matter how
little time you have
anyone can cook good food fast what an
absolute beauty
it's not bad is it unbelievable tornado
it is f3
f3 look at it my gosh more air force
finest
air defense fighter the best of the best
better the best dude in cooking terms
it's three michelin star twice the speed
of signs just over
5 000 miles an hour yeah a thousand
miles an hour just about that yeah yeah
you fancy trying to
go out for a ride well we'll try it
[Laughter]
the pilots can experience up to seven
times the force of gravity in the f3
so it's vital i wear the right kit
[Music]
oh god it's beautiful
that's amazing holy [ __ ] how close are
they
i'm hmm at 840 miles an hour that's 14
miles a minute
[Music]
thank you very much it's good fun
um i tell you what sport of kings
i can't eat a [ __ ] thing yeah i've
lost my appetite
i'm starving oh you're starving i'm
starving and you said you're gonna cook
for me so
[ __ ] they've shown me their skill in
the air
now it's time to get them up to speed in
the kitchen still feel a little bit
faint
all you need is a bit of food mate
better food yeah lunch
toast
i'm absolutely amazed you know i'm
gobsmacked on the back of what i've
experienced
and you know a [ __ ] thrill of a
lifetime without a shallow dab
you can't survive on a toasty so with
only 25 minutes until their next flight
i'm going to teach them how to cook
something that doesn't come between two
slices of bread
okay gentlemen i feel the need for speed
now yeah
something very simple straightforward um
stop timing i'm bloody good for you
yeah a really nice pan roasted cod with
chorizo
and a fragrant rice peeler
[Music]
sausages in fry off the chorizo
it gives a really nice flavor to the cod
a little bit of cherry vinegar
[Applause]
how long do i explain oh we have again
straight after this time to get a move
on
okay so onions in there that's for the
rice cardamon star
nice couple of cloves cinnamon stick the
smell of that now is amazing and for the
card we're gonna be cooking the cod on
the skin
okay hey it's packed with protein and it
keeps it nice and
intact you're laying it away just to
stop splashing
exactly that yeah the color on there now
is absolutely perfect
yeah this is a bit of a different sort
of take on a toasty for the guys yeah
what do you think they'll think can you
put that in a toaster
exactly a little check on our rice
and we're ready to serve up guys yeah
now for me the most important thing
there of course was the speed that
there's 12 minutes
happy this is fantastic yeah absolutely
good food
but fast food yeah it is yeah gentlemen
that was a [ __ ] pleasure yeah
i'm glad i got my appetite back yeah i'd
like to say thank you they're
extraordinary
yeah stay off the toasters yeah
yeah and i'll stay at your cockpit okay
[Music]
yeah touch that that's not cooked come
on back in quick backing back in quick
gently don't shake the pan you really
are a little suspect look at your
[ __ ] bowl
clean down my hot plate like spinach
just a touch just a touch no that is
olive oil gonna move you ladies
first table was [ __ ] great now we're
just going to pot let's go clean the
plates
table 11. yes you're happy left happy
good 11 go in here
very nice go we've all gone silent now
no one's talking to each other
let's go thank you very much
is it cooked that's like burns on the
yeah it's two minutes away from being
cooked yes that bit there
is beautifully cooked that bit in there
is raw
yes it's not good enough send it away
they want two fresh ones yeah please
yeah let's go yeah that's the most
amazing start yes yes
hold on the main course we've just
deflated such a shame
how long for your fish
we don't want it going out wrong that's
nice nicely cooked susan
yeah yeah okay as you lift the fish yes
make love to it don't [ __ ] it gently
watch out here come susan
watch out hi guys i'm here yeah nice
go 15. all right come here come here
come here
such a difficult fish to cook yes yes
but you've got to understand
it's better to be 30 seconds over 30
seconds under yes
yeah i hope the second time they went
out yeah
they were perfect yeah okay clear down
well done gas off yes
it's beautifully cooked very subtly
spiced and
totally worth the money i think the fish
is really lovely
it's really well cooked and really nice
balance with all the spices
i can't write results the commodities
yeah yes main course results let's go
oh my god okay
45 hours
jesus that means yeah if you get more
than 27 out of 50 customers paying for
the dessert
you'll knock those [ __ ] eaton boys
off
now that doesn't mean to say you take it
easy and coast for half a dollar
make sure that all 50 pay for those
desserts yes
next on the menu james may drinks his
way through the recipe challenge
if you win this [ __ ] challenge i'm
gonna go imagine that
it's time for dessert scotch pancakes
with caramelised bananas
and i go hunting with a winged assassin
he's got it he's got it bloody good
catch
[Applause]
welcome back to the f-word now time for
the recipe challenge and my challenger
is
james may yes captain slow so we may be
here for a long time
ready i'm ready how long will it take to
make the fish pie normally about four
hours
four hours yeah bloody hell i'll do it
one stage at a time you know because i'm
a pedant and then i go to the pub
so you're slow at driving and cooking
slower everything cool
so james is doing a fish pie i'm going
to do something very very similar except
i'm going to do a bit of a cream sauce
fresh basil new season peas grain
mustard that's the little sort of piss
the resistance
i just heard you describing yours mine
is nothing like as elaborate that mine
is fish with potato in the form of a pie
can i open this do you want to have a
bottle opener i have i've got my own
it's a proper waiter's friend but it's
got two steps in it which makes a
difference
in engineering terms so what fish have
you got in the pie
um i've got undyed smoked haddock
nice and um uh some white fish
i've got some shallots some fennel in
here just gonna sweat them down a little
bit of salt and pepper
a little bit of thyme and then i'm going
to add
the nolipra this is a verma and that's
going to help
make the sauce well all i've done so far
is peeled
roughly peeled and chopped up my
potatoes and my sweet potato
which is this thing i've only used half
of one that's just to inform
the flavor of the traditional mashed
potato now i'm gonna poach my fish
so you're cooking your fish in milk
james is that right yeah
this milk that the fish is poached in
will also become the basis
of the sort of sauce thing that fills up
the the bulk of the part i don't really
know what i'm talking about to be honest
usually by the time i get this far i'm
so drunk i can't remember what i've done
i'm gonna poach the prawns just in
seasoned water there a little bit of
lemon
thyme literally 30 seconds [ __ ] the
prawns i forgot the prawns man
james are you swearing in my kitchen
sorry you're putting the prawns into the
milk
yes yeah and the prawns are cooked
already i know but
they've just got to heat through
don't say i didn't
it makes me feel a lot more confident
that's very fast james there i think i'm
the first person in britain to actually
see captain slow go fast yeah
look at the speed of that knife well
it's because i've got the knife very
sharp
right these are ready
me rouey thing isn't thickening up
gordon is that
the roommate thing james you're the ruin
right now the rooi
the roo roux the roo okay the roux
is not going very thick it's a bit
sloppy does that matter uh depends how
thick you want your pie
the prawns are done are they yeah you're
right they have shrunk
i cocked that up a bit didn't i just to
finish all the potatoes now a little bit
of grated nutmeg
james do you always drink like this when
you're cooking doll's the horror of the
food that i'm going to eat later
obviously
if you win this [ __ ] challenge you
know i'm going to go mad you know that i
swear to god
just watching you yeah seriously drink
taste drink taste drink taste drink
taste extraordinary no that's great
nice yeah all i need to do is put my
multi-colored mashed potatoes on the top
and a bit of cheese
is that how you normally do paste it on
yeah well i asked you like a [ __ ]
plaster
now this is the bit you can obviously
honestly i would like a i'd like this
would you like a trowel
no i'd like a chef's tip how do i do the
middle this is the bit that i've always
struggled with
i would suggest you put it in your hand
cut it out paste it on there
patch it out pat it out on
and what james if i lose against that
seriously yeah i'm going to give up
cooking look mine against yours
yeah i know they're not cooked yet but
look at the color in mind though i mean
that's pretty
pretty cool there's a hair in it there i
don't want any [ __ ] hairs in my fish
pipe please quickly
no bug
right can we get in the [ __ ] oven now
no
james look at the time he's got to write
a word on the top
what are you putting on top [ __ ]
i've had that there next to yours the
last 10 minutes i hope the [ __ ] it
doesn't
affect it yes with shitness right ready
for the oven now yes
where is it uh uh i'll go bottom you'll
go bottom
right you've got your oven too hot yeah
no it's on 200 we've got to speed up a
little bit james just want it on about
80.
okay both pies in for half an hour oh
thank you yes half an hour later blind
tasers will taste them and then you'll
lose okay
how can you call yourself a chef ramsay
you haven't had a single drink
this series i'm hunting high and low for
great ingredients
i'm on my way to norfolk in search of
something quite unique something that
means a lot to me
hair is my favorite type of game they're
bigger and tastier than rabbit
but running at 40 miles an hour they're
harder to hunt
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm not going to be shooting the hair
i'm going to be using a bird of prey to
sort of
hunt it down shooting hair often results
in a spoiled carcass and hunting hair
with dogs have been banned
by using a bird of prey the meat is
killed cleanly and swiftly in a totally
natural way from a chef's point of view
a dream come true
i'm going to see george hedges who's
been a falconer all his life
[Music]
[Applause]
all these birds are lean mean killing
machines but to take down
a ham i need something bigger than a
falcon something huge
the ultimate bird of prey the golden
eagle
look at the size of it this is finick
he's absolutely [ __ ] gorgeous look at
the size of him extraordinary
god it's amazing yeah i'm going to put
that there the bro will step on jack
glove
yep okay can you hold him with that
there and you can feel the power [ __ ]
okay yeah
that's 3 000 pound yummy now right
tell you what let's even get invited
around oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] hold on tight here we go
it's okay now it's time for the hunt
once the eagle's airborne it's just a
matter of time until he spots her hair
okay effortless isn't it
oh come here old bastard
but once he's made the kill you've got
to be quick before the powerful bird
rips its prey
and your dinner apart oh he's got it
hey he's got it he's got it
[Music]
bloody good catch oh my god he's dead
yep yep here's dave bloody hell you can
see how quickly it's evolving that
already
no lead shot anywhere no nothing blasted
we'd never use the head anyway but
that's one perfect hair terrific just so
quick
it is brilliant i'm going to take the
hair back home and hang it for a couple
of days to improve the flavor
then i'm going to cook it for the kid's
tea that's the saddle and with that
we're going to do the most amazing
frequency
of hair with a rich dark chocolate sauce
and look
very gamey it's very rich very lean
that is a jewel in any kitchen
i throw in some shallots new season
turnips garlic and a little sugar
crush some juniper berries and black
peppercorns and chop some rosemary
now look at that wow everything in that
pan is so delicious
and gives a really nice foundation to a
quick frequency with the hair
now it's time for the kill loin in
one and a half to two minutes in there
the sad thing about hair never gets
looking because everyone's fascinated
with rabbit very lean
packed with protein and incredibly good
for you
pour some red wine into the pan and
reduce it add
our chicken stock bring it up to the
ball and then thicken it with a bit of
magic
chocolate bitter chocolate
add the hair and throw in some parsley
all right guys
dinner time tilly what do you think it
is
potatoes no fried meg the shore's
smell done gravy jack
tilly do you like that it's
hair i never guessed that
you've got chocolate in your nose
listen listen 45 out of 50 main
absolutely [ __ ] brilliant yeah
33 out of 50 disappointing pull it back
now in the desert okay
yes let's go justin six portions away
susan yeah
work together six portions away yeah
last course big moment come on
check out that caramel burn girl we've
got that right time for dessert scotch
pancakes we caramelize bananas and rum
and vanilla ice cream
pancakes why do we only eat them
february once a year strove tuesday
which is crazy
this is an american style pancake light
fluffy and absolutely delicious
start off with 150 grams of flour and
sieve the flour as you pour into the
bowl
baking powder keeps the pancake really
nice and light and fluffy
salt three eggs
75 mils of water and 120 ml of
buttermilk
and the secret behind this pancake mix
is to make sure that we've got no lumps
anywhere
whisk the eggs into the flour get your
buttermilk
just add half of it in
give it a really good whisk that's nice
and smooth already
the rest of the buttermilk and when you
make your pancake mix like this it's
chemistry so
follow the recipe exactly now we've got
this really nice
smooth batter that's ready perfect
non-stick pan sunflower oil and just run
that round
half a ladle in a minute and a half on
each side
palette knife in and over look
absolutely beautiful onto the plate
this is where it gets really exciting
we're caramelizing bananas
it's important to slice them lengthways
in order to make sure that they
don't go mushy in the pan i'm going to
make a really nice quick caramel
50 grams of sugar back onto the heat and
start the camera
don't whisk it don't put a spoon in
there just leave it in the pan once
you're happy with the color
take it back off the heat butter
bananas i'm gonna do now is deglaze the
pan with some rum
rum banana caramel it goes brilliantly
ramen
nice lovely
think of the flavor a little cup of
water
just to let the caramel down so it's not
too sticky and rich and too thick
there we go that's ready be generous
with them because it is just
the ultimate indulgence and then finally
to finish it some really nice ice cream
on top
and drizzle that over very very quick
and easy scotch pancakes
caramelised bananas with rum and vanilla
ice cream done
beautiful no one of the americans are so
[ __ ] fat
the caramel gets too hot take the pan
off yes
you're more than capable of doing this
yeah don't panic yeah oh [ __ ] let's go
move your ass turn it down it's too hot
susan [ __ ]
have i burnt these chefs [ __ ] out
ladies there's more swearing coming for
you for then there is me let's go
okay it's ready yes no why not call me
let's have messed up right they're too
dark
yeah too dark too dark too dark yes stop
stop stop stop some are nicely done some
are not done yes
get that [ __ ] out that's far too dark oh
toss them don't toss it be very careful
run quickly that's enough turn it around
come on please sandra look you've got to
help yourself now ladies and gentlemen
careful what's your eyebrows
ask you now right ready there we go
there you go out on the track pancakes
out let's sit good
come on please we're coming garden we're
coming can we dust the pancakes before
we put the bananas on okay
everything's done beautifully yeah we're
just stopping it no one gives a [ __ ] how
they put things on a plate here anymore
yes come on justine gotta wait at the
plate my darling yeah
you make all this amazing food and then
we just balls it up by dirtying
everywhere
judge chef yep are you happy with them
yes yes [ __ ]
service please
hello hello how are you my daddy i'm
very nice to you gentlemen good evening
how are you good to see you
nice to see you you look great thank you
how was the hell of it
very good did you join i'm very
impressed yeah yes beautiful great
daughter
fantastic excited about my dessert now
they're really good aren't they they're
doing a bloody good job
language is strong and on the ball
yeah you've always been a bit of a
foodie is there anything you'd never eat
i'm not a fussy eater really
yeah completely favorite kind of food is
uh comfort food
i think i've been spending lots of time
in the states so as soon as i came home
i wanted to have my roast
dinners and fish and chips l.a the
eating out scene there don't you get fed
up with sort of egg white helmets and
sort of tofu
i do but i don't i refuse to do it
because when i first arrived there i was
told
that you know it's very competitive and
that i should maybe lose consider losing
weight there's a bit rude isn't it would
you mind losing weight
otherwise you're not going to employ
well you know i was sat next to nicole
rich in a restaurant here he's
you know this tiny size zero she's like
that a stick insect
you just feel like going up to and say
hello is it a meal you're looking
forward to
thanksgiving very scary i don't like it
and i honestly think i'm so empty it
because i think
when you're in the public eye you are
you have a responsibility
yeah and my goddaughter is 14 years old
and she reads all these trashy magazines
and everything and she thinks that
is beauty you know it frustrates me from
a chess point of view that they sort of
get obsessed with not eating
eating well makes you feel well i just
love it one last question
you're a judge on um any dream will do a
panel of judges
you obviously go out for lunch from time
to time i do yes
doesn't andrew lloyd webber's face put
your food
send under my love i will i will i'll
send him down
good to see you thanks so much for
coming enjoy dessert yes
next on the menu hugh furley
whittingstall helps me put the spring
into spring lambs yes yes yes yes
[Applause]
[Music]
and i find out who beats who in the
recipe challenge um
so the winner the winner is
remember if you think you've got what it
takes to become the next big female tv
cook then send me a video
here are some of my favorites so far
i'm gonna start by cutting up some
ginger and some garlic you're gonna need
some olive oil
lay it down and then with the back of
the knife i'm saying that there should
be more women on television
more exciting women on television and
not just skinny blondes either
it looks really nice so many chefs
nowadays can't
quit go the wrong say look it's as brown
as me
eat your hat so making gingerbread men
might make gingerbread women
and the women have a little message for
you gordon
welcome back to the earthquake now time
for james may to lose the recipe
challenge ready to plate up ah
yes yes nice little description on there
it should be s-h-i-t yes
yeah right that's right yeah yours is
quite runny
what's that is that a yeah that's salmon
please don't finger my pie
right is that portion big enough james
mate
right jump up please please yes
obviously come back with the right
result
uh good luck yes yeah
hey hello how are you first dish
and this is your second dish
right over there looks wonderfully
don't test it try the other one you need
some salt in it
wrap papers in it this one looks pretty
oh that's got lobsters
that's lovely
[Laughter]
three two three two yeah we got two
um so uh the winner is
come on james oh yes
seriously yeah what
yeah with that pile of [ __ ] yeah
actually i love it it's cool no salt
are you any good at driving uh seriously
don't [ __ ] around jake
are you joking no no no no no no no no
too strong in flavors
beaten by a [ __ ] shaggy [ __ ] yeah
that's been four hours feeling these
[ __ ] potatoes
do something very quickly for me please
yes [ __ ] up
out of it please oh my god
i don't just want the sheep in my back
garden to grow i want them to grow up
happy welsh lambs charlotte and gavin
are now eight weeks old and
supplementing their milk with spring
grass
they're grown rapidly but i'm worried
they may be finding life in my garden a
bit dull
compared to the welsh mountains so i've
asked my friend hugh early wittenstahl
to come and check they're active enough
it's amazing how quick they're growing
you know yeah what do you think
what i can say is that those lambs are
growing well yes no question i mean
you're slightly skeptical about the
back garden i'm very skeptical but they
are wild
you've got wild sheep in the suburban
garden i mean
it's not like they're having a miserable
time here no not so but
it's it's not a welsh hillside is it
what we just need to do
here i think it's a little bit of
environmental enrichment
wanted to give the sheep a bit of extra
stimulation by giving them something to
climb on
there's your welsh mountain oh [ __ ]
they're having a laugh should we go and
brew up a couple yes
look gordon one of the lambs is sniffing
the mountain
she's interested look yes
yes yes yes yes
[Applause]
our little playground gives my lambs a
chance to tone up exercise
and generally enjoy life a bit more this
is literally the joys of spring that
we might have found a way to keep
charlotte and gavin amused but they're
stuck with the old lawn
my back gardens begin to look a bit
threadbare
i can't believe how quick they eat look
how patchy it is already there's not
much left is that
you know if they stay here much longer
you won't have a lawn
and they won't have anything to eat
we've got something to try and keep them
off the grass for a day or two nice
spring greens and kale
lovely and what do you think of their
size it's good enough for me
sweet isn't it you could be deep frying
that as seaweed greens and
selling it for 10 pounds of portion in
the restaurant i'm going to give it to
your sheep
come on girls these dorset greens will
give my sheep some extra nutrients and
minerals
but won't stop my lawn from being
devoured in a week's time there'll be
nothing left here
so i think you've got to find some other
grass so i think you have to get on the
phone to some of your friends
and see if someone else has got a nice
bit of garden who are you the regulars
at your restaurant who've got big
gardens in london
david victoria i'm sure they'd love to
have your sheep to stay wouldn't they
yeah uh well i'm gonna ask them yeah but
well get on the phone
who else tony blair do you think ten
downing street's got any grass
checkers got lots of grass checkers
that's not too far out of town no it's
not too far out
uh dear tony i was wondering if i could
ask you a favor i need to find new
pastures
davina yes hi am i done it's gordon how
are you
grass cross cross right mr jonathan ross
i'm sorry ah come on jonathan
here's gordon how are you dear mom yes
as an offer of the british empire i'm
writing to request your help
for a very important issue you can't
have the view in london
[Music]
it's the land free zombies a big
paradise right derma come on
i'll get back to you as soon as i can
damn johnny vaughan's got astro turf
and you've got no grass left dan that's
a no
lambs yes in my garden in your garden is
it possible
oh god and i do love lambs but my
husband's quite precious about his lawn
so i can't help take care my daddy dad
oh by the way p.s
i still polish my obe every day love
gordon
do you say love to the queen just when
things seem bleak i got lucky
you've really seriously pulled me out of
the [ __ ] i can assure you thank you oh
that's no problem okay we're done i'll
see you next week
thanks bye-bye-bye thank god for that
grass
thank you for cleaning the plate good
little bit of sauce ice cream too now
break away and do the ice cream good
girl
good now look at the difference this
table here look yes chef fantastic and
you're working the team and the bananas
aren't mushed
good that looks fantastic really good
well done girls and away
go [ __ ] off go well done last table
i really really enjoyed it it was it was
a good way to end
the meal that we had yeah it really did
take the box actually
it's just a nice combination of all the
different flavors and the pancake was
really
um nicely cooked
right ladies let's go results for the
desserts yes
give that to me please yes thank you
okay
working out right now for this next
course you need to have 27
or more to come back with the
possibility of running clarities
oh yes oh god
48 outfits
so that means you have a total of 126.
out of 150
yes which is [ __ ] good news yeah
that means more money than cents for the
eaton boys and
the lancia lasses are in pole position
well done
well done well done